bien en el vídeo anterior les mostré
este dato que parecía un dato bastante
loco así que en este vídeo vamos a ver
cómo llegamos a él así que empecemos
tenemos una configuración general para
este caso o este problemas de
optimización con restricción tenemos
esta función r que es una función que
queremos maximizar y en este caso las
considerando como los ingresos para
alguna compañía y además tenemos esta
función vemos que es la función
restricción la cual estoy considerando
como algún tipo de presupuesto para esta
compañía y como ustedes saben si han
llegado hasta este vídeo una manera para
resolver este ejercicio de optimización
es definir la función la granja no la
cual involucran a la función que estás
tratando de maximizar menos lambda bs es
la función del presupuesto
- ven y ven en este caso era el
presupuesto que habíamos definido en el
vídeo anterior como 10 mil pesos y bueno
lambda es el multiplicador de la granja
y observa qué
la granja no estaba definido para h para
am y para lambda y bueno el dato lo cual
que queremos llegar nos dicen que este
multiplicador de lagrange no es un
número del significante lo que nos dice
es que si encontramos una solución para
el gradiente de la granja nombre igual a
cero que haga que se maximicen esta
función r entonces a pesar de que
sabemos que la idea general de lambda
sale de aquí de esta constante de
proporcionalidad ahora lo que vemos es
que el abdi nos está diciendo cómo
cambian el ingreso máximo que podemos
obtener con respecto al presupuesto y es
que aquí hay algo muy importante estamos
considerando que el ingreso máximo que
podemos obtener lo podemos ver como una
función del presupuesto en este caso b
es el presupuesto y esta vez no va a ser
una constante como en el vídeo pasado
vamos a trabajar a ver como una variable
y si es una variable entonces
y estrellas dependen de esa vez estás de
acuerdo hay una relación muy implícita
que tal vez al principio sea difícil de
considerar pero a medida de que cambias
esta vez va a cambiar el valor que toma
la granja no y por lo tanto va a cambiar
el gradiente de la granja no lo que va a
hacer que cambien estos valores
h estrellas y estrellas cuando se haga
este gradiente igual a cero y se cambian
h estrella la estrella también va a
cambiar lambda estrella así que esta vez
vamos a suponer desde un principio que
estas tres son funciones del presupuesto
y si h estrella y ya estrella son
funciones debe entonces cuando las
metemos en esta función r me van a dar
el máximo de esta función r pero también
va a depender de ver por qué estas dos
funciones dependen de b entonces voy a
ser muy explícito que esta m
depende
déjame ponerlo de esta forma esta
estrella va a depender de la afirmación
que hice en el vídeo pasado es que está
lambda estrella es decir el valor de
lambda que viene envuelto con esta
estrella y esta estrella va a ser igual
a la derivada del valor máximo que
podemos alcanzar m estrella con respecto
al presupuesto y tal vez todo esto
parezca una especie de trabalenguas
incluso toma mucho decir lo que está
pasando pero en el contexto de un
ejemplo económico obtiene un significado
preciso y muy importante porque imagina
que tú aumenta su presupuesto un peso
pasas de 10.000 pesos a 10 mil pesos es
decir tienes un pequeño cambio en un
pequeño debe y ahora lo que te está
diciendo holanda estrella es por cada
peso que aumentes en el presupuesto que
tanto puede aumentar tu ingreso máximo
así que está increíble no crees pero
ahora la pregunta sería por qué es
cierto esto
en la tierra esto es válido porque si
observas por aquí parece que este
resultado salió de la nada y lo que
vamos a hacer aquí es demostrar que esto
en efecto es cierto y para demostrarlo
hay algunas observaciones inteligentes
que nos van a ayudar la primera es la
siguiente lo primero que voy a querer
hacer es evaluar el la gran que ha no en
estos valores h estrella a estrella
lambda estrella en este punto crítico
así que si los evaluamos me quedarían el
la granja no la granja long evaluado en
estos tres valores déjame escribirlo
evaluado primero en h estrella primero
en h estrella después en a estrella en
am estrella y también en lambda estrella
si nosotros ponemos estos tres valores
en de la granja lo que vamos a obtener
bueno primero recuerda que estos tres
valores hacen que el gradiente de la
granja no sea
a cero y recuerda si encontramos varios
puntos críticos que hagan de la granja
no igual a cero vamos a evaluar todos
ellos en la función r hasta encontrar el
máximo vamos a encontrar el punto
crítico que hagan que la función se
maximicen y ese punto crítico le vamos a
llamar h estrella a estrella blanda
estrella esto va a ser útil porque si
evaluamos esto me va a quedar que esto
es igual a la función r a la función r
evaluada en h estrella
como a estrella ok ya esto le voy a
quitar lambda estrella que multiplica a
bueno a la función fem evaluada en h
estrella evaluada el h estrella a
estrella ya esto le vamos a quitar a b b
que es nuestro presupuesto y puedo tal
vez podrán decirme por qué estoy
haciendo todo esto sólo estás
introduciendo las estrellas a algo que
ya sabíamos pero la clave aquí es que se
introducen a h estrella ya a estrellas
primero el valor de la función pm
evaluado en h estrella a estrella menos
este presupuesto esto me tiene que dar 0
y eso ya que tienen que satisfacer esta
restricción recuerden una de las partes
geniales acerca de esta función la gran
que anna es que cuando sacan la derivada
parcial con respecto a lambda entonces
esto
solamente obtienes la función verde
- ven porque la derivada de lambda con
respecto a la madame es 1 y si después
tomamos esa derivada igual a 0
entonces me quedan que la función de de
gea tiene que ser igual a el presupuesto
a esta b minúscula que habíamos definido
aquí y esto es porque la restricción te
mantiene el presupuesto alcanzan los 10
mil pesos eso cuando se introducen esta
h estrella y esta a estrella apropiadas
a este valor
recuerda no podemos gastar una infinidad
de dinero entonces esto de aquí como h
estrella y ya estrella son soluciones
del ejercicio de optimización entonces
toda esta parte de aquí va a ser igual a
cero esto va a ser cero y lambda
estrella por cero también se va a
cancelar entonces simplemente me quedan
con ere evaluada en h estrella a
estrella pero observa que esto que tengo
aquí es simplemente el
máximo es simplemente me estrella
entonces esto es m estrella y tal vez
sea evidente que cuando evaluamos en la
granja long en este punto crítico h
estrella a estrella lambda estrella me
dé pues simplemente m de estrella o tal
vez no sea tan evidente pero lo acabamos
de obtener entonces esto es lo que me
dan ela granjeando evaluado en este
punto crítico y es que finalmente lo que
queremos entender es cómo cambian este
valor máximo cuando lo consideras como
una función del presupuesto así que
claramente lo que vamos a buscar es
preguntarnos cómo cambia el la granja no
con relación al presupuesto es decir
estamos muy interesados en saber cuál es
la derivada de la granja no con respecto
a b y bueno tal vez estés tentado a
decir que viendo la definición de la
granja no esto me va a quedar
exactamente igual
y bueno aquí solamente tenemos a ver
entonces sería la derivada de esto con
respecto a ver sería hacer
la derivada de esto con respecto a b
sería 0 y solamente me quedaría lambda
vez que cuando lo derivamos con respecto
a b me quedarían simplemente lambda
entonces podrás decir sí claro por
supuesto la derivada de xela granjeando
con respecto a ver es la bda es todo lo
que estamos trabajando pero hay que
tener cuidado aunque suena convincente
esto no forzosamente es cierto porque el
problema es que la granja no no está
definido como función debe si lo
observas la definición de la granja no
no consideran ave como una variable por
lo tanto tal vez no sea completamente
cierto tomarnos esta derivada de la
granja no con respecto a ver y obtener
eso para poder tomarme la granja no como
una función debe lo que tendría que
hacer es lo siguiente definir ahora a la
granja no pero lo voy a definir como una
función debe y la forma en la que voy a
definirla es la siguiente me voy a tomar
a esta h estrella
h estrella pero ahora la voy a ver como
una función de ver porque hemos visto
que es una función de ver así que déjame
escribirlo h estrella debe o kate coma y
ahora me voy a fijar en esta estrella y
también voy a tomar a esta estrella como
función de ver a estrella debe porque
como vimos también depende de cómo
cambia el presupuesto y bueno también me
falta
fijarme en esta lambda estrella en esta
lambda estrella que como vimos también
es una función de ver entonces voy a
poner aquí lambda estrella estrella de
bem es una función que también va a
depender de be y esta vez voy a tomarme
una cuarta variable en este la granja no
mi cuarta variable va a ser la misma
porque bueno porque todas estas
funciones dependen de ben entonces
ve observa que podría decir que la
granja no es una función solamente deben
pero creo que se entiende más que aunque
todas éstas dependen de ven en la granja
no es una función multi variable y en
este caso de cuatro variables y para
hacerlo más explícito déjenme escribir
aquí en cada una de las definiciones que
teníamos aquí en el gran cañón pero que
ahora dependen de bien la función r que
dependen de h estrella porque recuerda
estamos evaluándolo en h estrella y en
la estrella pero ahora h estrella y
estrella dependen de v así que lo voy a
poner aquí a estrella y h estrellas
dependen de v ya esto le quitamos lambda
veces lambda estrella veces pero el
lambda ahora también es una función que
depende de b así que lo voy a escribir
aquí que a su vez multiplican que a su
vez multiplican a p mayúscula a la
función del presupuesto
depende de estrellas recuerda estamos
evaluando en h estrella que a su vez
depende de bem y también depende de la
estrella que a su vez en esta ocasión
también depende de be ok y a esto le
quitábamos le quitábamos bueno
simplemente en el presupuesto entonces
le quitábamos ven y déjame cerrar este
paréntesis observa que esta definición
que puse aquí es la definición explícita
de este la granja no en h estrella debe
a estrella deben lambda estrella de b&b
ahora recuerda tanto a estrellas como a
estrellas como lambda estrella hacen que
el gradiente de la granja no es decir de
toda esta función que tengo aquí el
gradiente de esta función sea igual a
cero pero bueno ahora h estrella a
estrella lambda estrella dependen de v
así que si ahora queremos evaluar la
derivada
esta función la granja na con respecto a
ven ahora si no puedo tomar esta
derivada porque observa ahora si es una
función que depende de p bueno pues esto
va a ser igual y para hacer esta
derivada lo que tenemos que utilizar es
la regla de la cadena la regla de la
cadena multivariable así que si en este
punto no conoces la regla de la cadena
multivariable puedes echarle un vistazo
al vídeo acerca de ese tema
definitivamente pausa el vídeo y ve a
ver el vídeo sobre la regla de la cadena
en este tipo de función multi variable
asegúrate de que entiendes todo esto muy
bien porque voy a suponer que ya conoces
la regla de la cadena multivariable
porque si ahora me tomo la derivada de
la granja no con respecto a b lo que
realmente voy a hacer es tomarme la
derivada de la granja no con respecto a
cada una de estas cuatro variables y a
su vez multiplicarlo por la derivada de
cada una de estas variables con respecto
a bien es utilizar simplemente la regla
de la cadena
entonces si me fijo en la primera
variable me quedaría la parcial de la
granja no con respecto a esta h estrella
y esto a su vez va a multiplicar déjame
ponerlo con este color esto a su vez
multiplicarían a la parcial de h
estrella con respecto a esta variable b
con respecto a b esto para la primera
entrada a esto le tendríamos que sumar y
bueno me va a pasar lo mismo aquí tengo
la parcial de la granja no con respecto
a esta estrella y esto a su vez va a
multiplicar a la parcial de la estrella
a estrella con respecto a esta nueva
variable ok ya esto le tendríamos que
sumar la parcial de la granja no con
respecto a lambda estrella a lambda
estrella esto que multiplica a la
parcial de lambda estrella con respecto
a b ok con respecto a b y por último le
tendríamos que sumar bueno observa mi
cuarta variables ven entonces tengo que
sumarle la parcial de la granja no con
respecto a b
y bueno aunque esto es un poco absurdo
vamos a ponerlo para terminar toda esta
derivada que buscábamos por la derivada
de la parcial de b con respecto a b
aunque sepamos que esto es 1 y ahora
seguramente estás pensando que esto está
terrible de calcular imagínense calcular
todo esto que tenemos aquí además
seguramente te vas a preguntar cómo
podremos obtener la derivada parcial de
h estrella con respecto a b y la
derivada parcial de estrella con
respecto a b y la derivada de lambda
estrella con respecto a b pero observa
lo siguiente nosotros ya sabemos que si
calculamos la parcial de esta es la
granja
con respecto a esta h estrella esto que
tenemos aquí es la primera componente
del gradiente de lambda evaluado en h
estrella y cómo está evaluado en h
estrella y h estrella hace que este
gradiente sea 0 entonces esta parcial va
a ser cero y 0 por lo que sea me da 0 y
va a pasar lo mismo aquí si cálculo la
parte de la granja no con respecto
a estrellas bueno esta es la segunda
componente del gradiente de la función
la granja nam evaluada en la estrella
pero a estrella hacía que esta segunda
componente fuera igual a cero por lo
tanto esto de aquí me quedaría cero por
esto que tengo aquí lo cual me va a dar
cero y va a pasar lo mismo para esto que
tengo aquí la parcial de la granja no
con respecto al hambre estrella es la
tercera componente de este gradiente de
la granja no porque lambda estrella hace
que esta tercera componente sea igual a
cero entonces esto también se va así que
si observo que este es simplemente uno
ahora puedo concluir que la parcial de
la granja no con respecto a b es igual a
la parcial de la granja no con respecto
a bien y me vas a decir bueno y que
tiene que lleguemos a esta respuesta
bueno lo que pasa es que si ahora
observas que ésta ya es una función de
cuatro variables entonces podemos ver
cuál es la derivada de esta función la
gran henna con respecto de tal vez sea
más fácil teniendo todas las estrellas
que le pongan
hombre de la granja no estrella y
entonces aquí lo que quiero tomarme es
la parcial de la granja no estrella con
respecto a ver pero ahora lo importante
es que aquí no tenemos a una vez de
manera explícita entonces cuando calculó
la derivada con respecto a ver esto se
eliminan esta parte de aquí también se
eliminan y solamente me quedaría la
derivada de lambda estrella que es una
función de b por b y si calculó esa
derivada con respecto a b esto de aquí
me va a dar simplemente esto de aquí me
va a dar simplemente lambda estrella
lambda estrella que bueno sabemos que es
una función de ver déjame especificar la
lambda estrella de
es decir lo que hicimos fue escribir a
esta es la granja no estrella como una
función multi variable de cuatro
variables pero tres de estas variables
están bloqueadas porque son los valores
donde evaluamos a esta función la granja
nam para que su gradiente se hiciera
igual al vector cero entonces podríamos
decir que esta función de la granja no
estrella solamente depende de si cambia
bien cambian estos tres valores pero
estos tres valores están bloqueados y
tal vez esto sea un punto que parezca un
poco confuso con toda esta anotación de
las estrellas y bueno no estoy de
acuerdo con ustedes pero aquí la parte
importante la parte importante que vale
la pena recordar es que sólo empezamos
considerando avn como una variable y
cuando b empezó a ser una variable
cambió todo porque entonces h estrella
debe a estrella devin y lambda estrella
deben son funciones que ahora dependen
de la variable be y también por otra
parte hicimos la observación que m
h estrella a estrella blanda estrella es
aquel punto crítico donde si evaluamos
esta función la granja nam obteníamos
simplemente m estrella entonces ahora sí
puedo decir que la derivada parcial de m
estrella que es una función que depende
de ver déjame ponerlo así m estrella
debe esté con respecto a b
esto va a ser igual bueno está derivada
parcial está evaluada en el punto
crítico por lo tanto todo esto se
cancelarían y me quedo simplemente con
lo que buscaba con lambda estrella de b
déjenme escribirlo lambda estrella de
ven que es a lo que queríamos llegar así
que si quieres conocer la derivada del
ingreso máximo con respecto al
presupuesto vale la pena fijarse en el
valor que toman lambda estrella el
multiplicador de lagrange en el punto
crítico que por cierto es lo mismo que
la derivada parcial de la granjearon con
respecto al presupuesto así que mientras
estemos considerando todo esto en el
punto crítico en los valores de h.stern
a estrella y lambda estrella todo esto
se reduce de una manera agradable a
sacar esta derivada parcial que nos dan
justo la relación que buscábamos